vous avez été l'avocat entre autres de
Simone Weber la diabolique de Nancy du
non moins célèbre routard du crime
Francis Holmes ou encore de celui que
fait entrer l'accusé à finement baptisé
le coupable innocent Jacques maire
autant de clients qui ont détruit la
chronique judiciaire comment vous êtes
vous retrouvez dans cette dossiers
déjà vous remarquerez une chose c'est
que ce sont des dossiers locaux quand
même
je suis un peu spécialisée dans le
criminel lorrain
c'est gênant de faire son auto aux
promotions si vous voulez j'étais parmi
les quelques pénalistes de l'endroit la
première rencontre avec l'accusé souvent
déterminante dit-on c'est celle qui
guide finalement la relation
qu'entretient l'avocat à son client
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui se
joue qui se dit ou qui se noue parce que
paraît-il que lors des premiers contacts
on n'évoque pas les faits reprochés
est-ce que c'est vrai ça mais déjà il y
a un grand saut que personne d'autre que
l'avocat ne peut faire finalement
c'est qu'on passe quelque part d'une
image à une personne pour ne pas dire
d'un mythe à une personne parce que
Simone Weber c'était déjà un mythe quand
elle était en détention et vous vous
trouvez face à une personne humaine
voilà et ça c'est déjà un grand saut
êtes-vous du côté des avocats tel un
Thierry Moser le conseil de la famille
Villemin qui ont besoin d'être
convaincus de la sincérité de leurs
clients pour bien les défendre où
êtes-vous du côté de ceux comme André
buffa qui disent que le job de l'avocat
défendre en aucune façon de rechercher
la vérité
où vous situez-vous
moi je suis là pour défendre mon client
c'est peut-être un peu simpliste ça
manque peut-être de subtilité mais je
suis là pour ça et pas pour autre chose
donc vous n'êtes en aucune façon de
celles qui se désistent si vous avez la
certitude que votre client ne dit pas la
vérité ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance
au fond vous êtes prêt à le défendre à
n'importe quel prix bah déjà première
chose et ça me paraît être un préalable
indispensable c'est pas n'importe quel
prix je ne lui demande pas la vérité
chaque fois que je le peux je regarde le
dossier d'abord
et le client me dit des choses qui sont
soutenables ou non
[Musique]
et si ça n'est pas soutenable j'aurais
même pas à dire à la personne que je la
défends pas vous avez la défense dans la
peau jusque parfois pousser les choses
très loin je pense notamment au rapport
de force avec la magistrat que vous
pouvez mettre en place et qui vire
parfois au Grand Guignol faire
comparaître l'un de vos clients
historiques Francis Heaulme pour ne pas
le nommer dans le procès d'un autre de
vos clients Jacques maire c'était pour
le moins inhabituel oui et non Francis
Heaulme on le met en cause dans tout un
tas d'affaires qui n'ont pas concerné
vous vous ne le voyez pas puisque c'est
des pistes qui n'aboutissent pas mais
quand même on le met en cause et puis
finalement
j'allais dire on le fait des excuses je
suis optimiste on lui dit maintenant bah
c'est fini non vous n'avez rien à voir
là-dedans ce qu'on a fait pour Francis
Heaulme on peut le faire aussi pour
jacquemer vous voyez
donc c'est intéressant de voir qu'on
peut inquiéter des gens qui de toute
évidence n'ont rien à voir là-dedans oui
mais si tu es à comparaître un homme qui
n'avait fondamentalement rien à dire
dans ce procès bon c'est pas n'importe
quel détenu Francis il est à la fois
très célèbre et très Oni est-ce que son
témoignage était absolument
indispensable ou est-ce qu'il y a
admettez le quelque chose de surjoué au
fond votre confrère Hervé tes mime pense
quand tout avocat sommeille un acteur
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
pas du tout pas du tout en tout cas pas
pour moi si vous voulez on dit les
avocats les avocats c'est plusieurs
métiers chacun son tempérament chacun à
sa façon de voir et au fond on n'est pas
d'accord entre nous et c'est bien ainsi
si vous voulez et moi je ne suis pas du
tout sur cette ligne de défense qui
consiste à dire si je le dis bien ça
marchera c'est un peu ça finalement
c'est pas c'est pas la question d'y
croire ou de ne pas y croire je trouve
que quelque part quand même dans une
société démocratique au 21e siècle c'est
dramatique qu'on est que ça pour
défendre quelqu'un qui est au prise avec
la justice parce que en fait on a
pratiquement que ça on est dans un
système judiciaire ou l'avocat est mal
vu où il a pas beaucoup de pouvoir pas
beaucoup de possibilités et au fond il
n'a que des mots pour défendre son
client on viendra nous raconter que dans
le temps de la procédure on peut
demander au juge d'instruction on peut
demander de désigner un expert qu'on
n'aura pas choisi qui sera inscrit sur
une liste établie par l'accusation et
expertise à laquelle on assistera pas
donc c'est vrai que la défense en droit
français ce sont les mots d'accord et si
les mots ne sont pas lourds de
conviction et de sincérité à mon avis ça
ne marche pas et j'ai entendu Henri
Leclerc dire
je crois qu'il fait une excellente
synthèse parce que il dit pas il peut
m'arriver d'être cabotin il dit quand je
le dis je le crois a-t-elle enseigne
qu'il faut même quelquefois que mes
confrères me disent attends tu l'as
vraiment cru et le clair de répondre au
moment où je l'ai dit oui je l'ai cru ce
que vous dites au fond c'est que la
justice assez biaisée parce que la
défense a peu de place est-ce que
défendre l'un des formats c'est
l'essence même de votre métier c'est
donner corps à votre serment c'est à la
fois un devoir et un honneur
ah ben oui complètement c'est c'est en
effet un devoir et un honneur de
défendre on ne défend pas que
l'indéfendable bien sûr mais parce que
déjà c'est c'est une expression qui est
quand même plus journaliste que
juridique et qui est pas forcément
dans l'esprit de plus en public vous
savez dans l'esprit de l'opinion
publique si on compare des sociétés
différentes etc des époques différentes
le curseur est pas au même endroit il y
a eu des époques ou quasiment pour tout
le monde le blasphème était ce qu'il y
avait de plus grave on a quand même bien
évolué depuis donc
l'indéfendable déjà l'indéfendable ça
n'existe pas et en plus notre profession
défend celui qui est seul aux prises en
fait pour les affaires graves c'est même
pas avec la justice seulement c'est avec
la société bon
et je crois que c'est une question qui
ne se pose pas en fait la vraie vérité
c'est que c'est une question qui ne se
pose pas un avocat doit défendre celui
qui a commis même le pire avec une
limite sauf si vous ne vous sentez pas
capable de le faire parce que ça serait
au détriment du client c'est une clause
de conscience
vous avez vous-même perdu un enfant on
vous demande de défendre un meurtrier
d'enfant attendez on peut pas exiger ça
ça sera voilà mais autrement c'est sûr
que si personnellement on n'est pas
spécialement impacté et ben oui il faut
y aller c'est presque un devoir civique
alors il faut y aller personne le
saviez-vous personne ne voulait plaider
pour le tueur en série Michel Fourniret
il a fallu des avocats commis d'offices
au contraire de Francis Heaulme sur
lequel nombre d'avocats louchait comment
expliquer vous ça
ah parce que ces deux affaires qu'on
peut pas comparer je le répète depuis
des années quand même maintenant j'ai
pas plaider toutes ces affaires mais il
y en a quand même un certain nombre en
ce qui concerne Francis Saul et j'espère
si c'est pas moi qu'on doit tant pis
j'espère que vous voyez depuis le temps
que j'en parle ça quand même quelque
part modifié son son image Francisco
mais majoritairement passé pour un
prédateur
cynique pervers qui jouit du malheur et
de enfin de la mort d'autrui mais c'est
pas du tout ça Francis Heaulme
[Musique]
c'est en tant que personne une
production de notre société c'est pas sa
faute s'il est comme ça Francis holla on
va me dire c'est facile mais c'est aussi
un bon bouc émissaire Francisco c'est un
personnage qui n'a pas la capacité de se
conduire normalement qui a été produit
par une société qui ne veut pas
l'assumer c'est quand même ça et
condamné Francisco le main ça dédouane
le reste de la société faut pas s'y
tromper et Francis Heaulme c'est mon
client j'aime pas employer des mots
péjoratifs mais à une époque où il y
allait quelquefois dans les expressions
on aurait dit c'est un idiot de village
c'est quand même pas du tout la même
chose et je dois dire que pour ma part
moi je suis contente de défendre Francis
hole qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la fin
programmée des jurés populaires ah
quelle catastrophe quelle catastrophe
le droit de juger appartient au peuple
et pas à l'école de la magistrature
exactement exactement quand vous vous
dites que pour les cas les plus graves
qui vont impacter toute la vie de celui
qui est accusé c'est quelqu'un qui a été
reçu à un concours de grandes écoles
et ben même si ces gens-là sont éminents
et il y a de très bons juges parce que
si on a encore si on en a l'occasion moi
je pense qu'on a un mauvais système
judiciaire au pénal avec de temps en
temps souvent la proportion reste à
déterminer un résultat qui est correct
parce qu'on a des bons juges on fait
fonctionner la justice sur la qualité
des juges et non pas sur la qualité du
système donc je ne mets pas en cause la
qualité des juges mais je dis que au
fond en plus c'est une charge morale
qu'on n'a pas à leur imposée
viscéralement attaché à l'oralité des
débats or les cours criminels
départementales avec des magistrats
professionnels sont en train de les
remplacer
on en a déjà une expérience et on reste
dans l'oralité des débats il faut il
faut voir une chose pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a fait ces cours criminels parce
que on n'arrive plus la justice est
engorgée jusqu'au niveau criminel c'est
pas autre chose et on n'arrive plus à
purger les affaires on s'est dit on va
faire des cours criminels parce que ça
ira plus vite et ça plus simple c'est
dans une logique d'abattage voilà
en tout cas de purger
les dossiers qu'on n'arrive pas à juger
quoi c'est ça la réalité et donc on va
faire plus simple alors on met là dessus
de grandes raisons des juges
professionnels c'est mieux etc au départ
d'ailleurs c'est quoi criminel
départemental était provisoire on devait
faire un audit c'était un essai
aujourd'hui le provisoire qui dure alors
il y en a une près de chez moi à Metz et
si vous voulez l'expérience des montres
par exemple que les les audiences dure
le même temps une affaire qui se jugée
en trois jours et toujours jugé en trois
jours on fait venir il fallait entendre
deux experts on fait venir les deux
experts donc
on gagne pas de temps du tout et je ne
pense pas qu'il y a un bénéfice sérieux
à procéder de cette façon là parce que
vous savez qu'est-ce qu'on économise on
économise
l'espèce d'intendance qui consiste à
établir les listes de jurés à les
vérifier avoir ce qu'il faut enlever etc
c'est vrai que c'est une espèce
d'ingénierie qu'il faut mais ça change
rien ça c'est pas ça le vrai problème et
les audiences durent le même temps et ça
va pas mieux quelle est l'écueil de
cette réforme à terme et ben écoutez je
pense que le public va se désintéresser
de plus en plus de la justice
et ça c'est pas une bonne chose le
public c'est déjà des intéressés de la
politique comme le fonctionnement de la
vie politique est difficile à percevoir
les gens disent je retourne à mes
oignons c'est à dire à ma vie et je
pense que la justice va ça va être la
même chose et c'est quand même grave
c'est grave parce que
l'acte de juger c'est pas anodin et que
pour qu'il y ait une vraie
légitimité déjà il faut pas une seule
personne qui juge et il faut un espèce
d'échevinage entre le public et les
juges
autrement la légitimité et pour les
choses graves on certes on a pu la peine
de mort mais une perpétuité
incompressible comme on dit
c'est quand même quelque chose
et pour que ça reste quelque chose
vraiment de légitime d'honnête il faut
que
le peuple participe que tout le monde
participe en plus notre cour d'assise
qui a des jurés elle a quand même un
autre défaut c'est que
à l'instant de la vie politique
d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression qu'en
France on aime bien les régimes
présidentiels la cour d'assises est un
régime présidentiel le président fait
tout il accuse il défend etc l'avocat
général il pose une ou deux questions
résiduelles l'avocat de la défense
pareil avant de parler à la fin mais on
a déjà un président qui est
omniprésent on le sait à travers les
témoignages plus ou moins officielles de
juré
concernant le délibéré ce qui se passe
un peu dans la salle derrière où on se
réunit avec ce qui s'est passé dans le
procès de Simone Weber je crois alors
pour une fois parce que vous savez que
le secret du délibéré à la différence
d'autres secrets et quand même très
sévèrement gardé c'est quand même un an
de prison 15000 euros d'amende et puis
une poursuite qui existent bon et c'est
vrai que dans l'affaire Simone Weber
c'est étonnant d'ailleurs parce que
l'affaire est vieille mais tout le monde
s'en souvient si man Weber est encore
vivante il y a quand même il y a un ou
une durée qui avait témoigné dans l'Est
Républicain exactement 2015 2015 c'est
une de vos concurrents qui a fait c'est
donc sur la voie publique qui
particulièrement choquée quand même dit
que
se retirant dans la salle derrière à
l'arrière de l'audience le président a
mis la main sur le dossier a dit ça ça
vaut perpète donc il a orienté
le président manifeste son opinion
et en même temps il témoigne de son
impérialisme quelque part dans la cour
d'assis françaises il est le seul qu'on
puisse pas enlever à la limite il peut
faire l'audience à lui tout seul et six
semaines d'audience c'est rare quand
même pour une affaire criminelle de
droit commun on va dire qui n'est pas du
terrorisme
et plus l'audience est longue
plus les jurés prennent du pouvoir parce
que la justice est un lieu de pouvoir on
le sait bien et là il y a eu six
semaines et ils ont pu contrebalancer le
pouvoir du président parce que cette
durée ou se jurer dit des choses
positives il dit j'ai l'impression
d'avoir pu peser pour qu'on soit juste
bah écoutez si ça ça ne démontre pas
nécessité garder les journées d'assises
c'est quand même une belle démonstration
vous parliez d'impérialisme
notoriétarisme Simone Weber s'est révélé
à son procès en diva du fait dive en
reine de la réplique elle a transformé
le tribunal en salle de spectacle elle
connaissait sur le bout des doigts les
18000 pages de son dossier d'instruction
comment défendons il y a une Glock quand
on a affaire à une cliente qui mène
elle-même les débats et joue à guichet
fermé comment on existe auprès d'elle
déjà Simone Weber si vous voulez c'est
quelqu'un qui tenait ses avocats en
respect oui
et je crois que il fallait faire la même
chose et c'est ce que j'ai fait
c'est à dire lui tenir la dragée haute
quelque part mais en acceptant le
acceptant le retour voilà notamment par
exemple elle avait pris l'habitude de
critiquer ses avocats auprès du juge
d'instruction éventuellement par écrit
mon avocat Intel a fait ça parce que
c'est nul je suis pas d'accord moi j'ai
mis des bornes immédiatement je lui ai
dit Madame Weber si vous voulez me
critiquer vous me le dites ou vous me
dites que on s'est vu suffisamment
longtemps mais j'accepte pas de voir au
dossier quand je vais le consulter une
lettre où vous vous plaignez de moi je
l'ai dit une fois il y a jamais eu de
problème mais d'un autre côté aussi
pareil moi je respectais son caractère
elle a accusé les jurer elle-même on
n'avait jamais vu ça il y avait quelque
chose de très théâtral elle a été
victime plusieurs fois de malaise on se
souvient notamment d'elle sortant sur
une civière de la cour d'appel de Nancy
est-ce qu'il y a aussi une part de
théâtralité aux assises et dans ce
procès en particulier sincèrement
qu'est-ce que vous en dites s'il y a une
part de théâtralité
c'est rarement l'accusé dans ce procès
on y vient
autrement je dirais plutôt non de la
part de l'ensemble des accusés
maintenant on a des procès qui sont
matinés de politique on a les procéder
terrorisme tout ça c'est une autre
histoire mais le pénal traditionnel vous
savez l'accusé il est quand même dans la
cage en verre en ce qui concerne Simone
Weber c'est un cas un peu particulier
elle était Atral mais oui voilà je veux
dire quand on allait la voir au parloir
de la prison il n'y a pas de public là
mais elle était la même moi j'avais pas
le sentiment de quelqu'un qui jouait la
comédie à l'audience elle était
elle-même et c'était peut-être pas
d'ailleurs une bonne idée d'être
elle-même après
enfin moi je sais que cette histoire de
récuser les jurés j'étais à fond contre
je lui ai dit je vous le dis si vous
voulez le faire vous le faites c'est
tout mais il faut pas quoi c'est
antipathique de récuser et puisqu'on a
parlé de cette jurée qui s'est exprimée
elle a dit une chose très intéressante
et qui me renvoie dans les cordes je
crains pas de le dire
elle dit à travers la récusation celui
qui n'est pas récusé à l'impression
d'être choisi ce qui est très juste et
ce juré dit
ou la s'entendre mais en tout cas c'est
ça le message
j'ai senti que c'était tel qui m'avait
choisi et non pas l'avocat
bah j'avais peut-être tort c'est
peut-être elle qui avait raison Lignan
Glock vous êtes aussi l'avocat duhamas
comment devient-on l'avocat d'une
organisation terroriste en tout cas tel
que l'Union européenne la définit et en
plus j'ai été leur avocat sur ce sujet
il s'agit pas de conseils sulfureux ou
je ne sais quelle histoire ils sont
inscrits sur la liste terroriste
européenne et
ils ont souhaité à un moment donné en
sortir demander à en sortir ils en sont
sortis au Luxembourg je crois qu'il les
a très momentanément très momentanément
mais enfin pour un avocat c'est quand
même un plaisir si vous voulez parce que
c'est un tout petit séisme dans les
conséquences mais c'est un tout petit
séisme momentané mais planétaire
c'est quand même la réalité mais quand
toute modestie comment devenez-vous
l'avocat des Palestiniens d'ailleurs
vous portiez un certain moment le kéfié
c'est simplement j'ai eu pour client un
Palestinien de Nancy pour une question
de titre de séjour et ce palestinien
avait créé une association pour
collecter quelques sous de fil en
aiguille je suis allée en Palestine
comment je suis devenue l'avocat du
Hamas parce que j'étais sur place pour
des raisons humanitaires et qu'on a
demandé à me voir en ce qui concerne
cette procédure à Luxembourg devant une
juridiction européenne ces gens-là m'ont
reçu c'était des chefs bien entendu et
ils m'ont donné une demi-heure pour
m'expliquer avec un traducteur et en une
demi-heure ils sont décidés que oui on
faisait la procédure
j'étais un peu à la fois surprise et
merveilleux quand même et il s'agissait
de quelque chose je vous dis de très
correct c'était enfin c'est une démarche
positive de leur part on peut le dire
sans faire l'éloge de cette entité comme
dit l'Europe mais il demande à sortir de
la liste ça veut dire qu'il s'en fiche
pas bien sûr c'est quand même quelque
chose de tout à fait positif mais votre
combat auprès d'eux ne s'inscrit pas
dans une démarche politique matinée
nationalisme comme ça puait le cas pour
Jacques Vergès par exemple non pas du
tout c'est rien de politique c'est
vraiment juridique et je trouve
justement aussi parce que quand vous
faites partie des de des entités
terroristes c'est comme ça que sa figure
la démarche qui consiste à dire oui on
le fait moi j'étais épaté qui décide en
une demi-heure de confier leurs intérêts
à une blonde
quand même
et après d'ailleurs où j'ai pu
entretenir avec eux de bons rapports
le client qui me font confiance qui me
demandent sur les questions juridiques
etc c'est quand même assez surprenant
j'aimerais revenir sur Jacques maire
Jacques maire a été condamné en première
instance plus lourdement condamné en
appel avant d'être finalement acquitée
par la Cour de cassation pour un vice de
procédure c'est cela la justice je le
dis sans aucune ironie est-ce que c'est
cela la justice précisément alors en
fait la Cour de cassation ne l'a pas ne
l'a pas acquitté à la renvoyer devant
une troisième cour d'assise c'est ça qui
était un peu il y a eu trois audiences
d'assis c'est pas toujours bon
maintenant on a l'exemple de l'affaire
des enfants de Montigny où là et en
effet il y a eu aussi une cascade de
cour d'assises et il a donc été acquitté
par la Cour d'assise de Metz
actuellement et ces deux affaires là
sont quand même que ça soit Jacques
maire ou la faire des enfants de
Montigny c'est des dossiers sur lesquels
on revient très tardivement et la
justice fait ce qu'elle peut avec ce
qu'elle a avec des dossiers ou les
scellés ont disparu u enfin voilà des
choses comme ça et
bah oui c'est rendre la justice moi je
vais pas vous dire que ça me satisfait
et pourquoi
parce que si vous voulez ma conso
ma conserveau parlait beaucoup mieux que
moi parce qu'elle s'est un peu
spécialisée sur cette question moi je
suis complètement pour le droit l'oubli
il faut savoir rechercher la vérité il
faut savoir faire un procès mais il faut
aussi savoir fermer la porte on ne peut
pas éternellement vivre dans la
procédure c'est mauvais pour tout le
monde c'est mauvais pour les accuser qui
ont plus de mal à se défendre mais c'est
mauvais aussi pour les victimes quelle
calvaire d'être victime pendant des
décennies c'est affreux quand même quand
on y pense mais les descendants des
victimes de Jacques maire continuent à
demander réparation qu'est-ce qu'on dit
à ces plaignantes qui ont soif de
justice et qui ont le sentiment que la
justice ne les ne les écoute pas ne les
entend pas qui elles ont sentiments qui
a un déni de justice précisément parce
qu'il y a prescription avec ou sans
prescription parce que qu'on refasse un
procès bancal ou qu'on ne fasse pas de
procéder du tout ce n'est pas la justice
qui les aidera à vivre et voilà
faire le deuil
c'est la justice ça doit justement
permettre de mettre un terme à un drame
quand la décision est rendue c'est fini
c'est pas là-dessus que les victimes
contrairement à ce que certains pensent
chacun a le droit d'avoir son opinion et
moi aussi je ne pense pas qu'on se
reconstruit à partir d'une décision de
justice ça vous permet justement au
contraire d'avancer de dire ça c'est
fini c'est plus ma vie et regardez
toujours en arrière vers une justice qui
n'a pas été parfaite qui a été peut-être
insatisfaisante c'est se boucher
l'avenir mais pratiquement jusqu'à votre
mort quoi je crois qu'à partir d'un
certain moment faut dire c'est fini je
n'aurais pas de réponse il y a plein de
domaines dans lesquels on n'aura pas de
réponse et il faut l'accepter parce que
autrement on entretient son malheur et
on en sortira jamais vous avez longtemps
formé de fait vous avec Francis Heaulme
un vieux couple judiciaire c'est le
client de votre vie Francis Hollande
c'est le Joseph Vacher des temps
modernes oui mais si vous voulez
francisole moi c'est j'arrive à
m'interpeller moi-même le fait par
exemple qui continue à me téléphoner
Simone Weber me téléphone régulièrement
de manière espacée mais Francisco ne me
téléphone toutes les semaines
[Musique]
on m'a déjà posé la question mais à quoi
ça tient pourquoi bon
je crois qu'en fait c'est le moment du
procès ou
ses cours mais vous êtes tout pour votre
client si vous voulez ce qui crée ce
lien que je n'arrive pas à définir parce
que
ça ne vient devient pas votre ami
c'est-à-dire pas votre pote vous devenez
pas un membre de sa famille c'est rien
de tout ça que ça soit pour Francis
hollyone Weber c'est pas ça et en
cherchant à réfléchissant moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est
d'avoir vécu ensemble un moment
périlleux c'est ça si vous voulez le
procès criminel entre l'accusé et son
avocat on est sur un radeau et
celui qui est en meilleure état c'est
l'avocat et qui peut peut-être tirer
l'autre de là je crois que c'est ça qui
fait que Simone Weber continue à nous
téléphoner que Francis Heaulme me
considère comme proche
sans savoir pourquoi finalement ce qu'il
est c'est pas mon talent
que je n'ai ou que je n'ai pas mon
talent relatif c'est qu'ils ont
confiance en moi ces gens-là ont
vraiment confiance en moi pour n'importe
quoi vous récusiez au début de notre
entretien le mot d'indéfendable est-ce
que vous diriez néanmoins que vous êtes
l'avocat de l'impossible
oui
l'avocate de l'impossible dans certains
cas certainement parce que il y a des
buts dont on sait qu'on ne les atteindra
pas même si on a la conviction que le
client peut être innocent on sait que
l'acquittement on ne l'aura pas je
savais que franciseau il ne serait pas à
quitté c'est quoi
défendre les gens il est l'accusé
indéfendable à quel niveau qu'est-ce que
vous espérez moi je vais vous dire sur
en ce qui concerne les personnes qui ont
reconnu les faits je trouve qu'on a une
justice criminelle qui est mauvaise
pourquoi
parce que celui qui reconnaît l'effet et
je vais certainement
choquer des gens parmi le public je
considère que celui qui reconnaît
l'effet on pourrait lui éviter la cage
en verre
l'aveu n'est pas valorisé comme il
devrait l'être et celui qui avoue au
fond n'y gagner rien il va quand même
subir un procès d'assise où on va lui
dire ah vous reconnaissez les faits
malheureusement quand même c'est la
moindre des choses et c'est quand même
pas parce qu'il reconnaît que ça y est
l'ardoise est effacée voyez c'est ça les
réflexions l'accusé qu'il avoue non il a
toujours tort et je trouve qu'on
pourrait rémunérer quand même de manière
plus significative celui qui reconnaît
les faits et ça s'appelle le plaid des
coupable si on avait cette possibilité
mes clients à vous ré 8 fois sur 10
parce qu'ils l'ont fait parce qu'il
serait d'accord voilà ils l'ont merci
dylian Glock merci à vous également